problema número 221 resuelva esta
operación uno más uno entre uno más uno
entre uno más un test y vamos paso a
paso esto es igual a tener todo esto uno
más uno entre uno más
uno entre y esto uno más un tercio y lo
mismo que tener tres tercios más un
tercio es lo mismo que tener aquí cuatro
tercios uno entre todo esto es lo mismo
que tener el recíproco de esta parte por
lo que me queda uno más uno entre uno
más tres cuartos el recíproco esto es lo
mismo que tener cuatro cuartos más tres
cuartos o lo que es lo mismo siete
cuartos entonces esto es igual a uno más
uno entre siete cuartos
pero esto es lo mismo que tener el
inverso de este denominador por lo que
es igual a 1 + 4 séptimos todo esto es
lo mismo que tener 7 séptimos que es lo
mismo que un entero más 4 séptimos 7 más
4 es igual a 11 séptimos que es mi
opción de siguiente problema problema
número 222 del siguiente sistema
rectangular coordenada si el punto r que
no se muestra se encuentra sobre la
parte positiva del eje y el área del
triángulo o pr o el punto r que no se
muestra aquí el área del triángulo
formado por esos puntos es de 12 cuál es
la coordenada del punto r bueno entonces
me están pidiendo la coordenada de un
punto r que todavía no conozco sé que
está sobre el eje y de manera que su
coordenada x va a ser cero y bueno aquí
voy a ponerle como la variable que
representa el valor en y de éste la
línea que una r con p me va a formar un
triángulo con esto con los ejes un
triángulo rectángulo cuya área cuya área
estoy sombra andraca es igual a 12 bueno
como encontramos el área de un triángulo
pues va a ser base por altura entre 2
aquí la base esta parte de acá vale 4 y
la altura no la conozco sería el valor
de g si escribo la fórmula el área que
es 12 es igual a la base que es 4 por la
altura que es por un medio o entre 2
si yo despejó ye de esto voy a encontrar
su valor bueno 4 por un medio es igual a
2 así que 2 y es igual a 12 por lo que
ya es igual a 6 y es mi opción b es
estuvo bastante rápido veamos el
siguiente problema problema número 223
él a esta 20 km atrás del autobús que
viaja por el mismo camino y en la misma
dirección que el auto a viaja a una
velocidad constante de 50 kilómetros por
hora y el auto ve viaja a una velocidad
constante de 50 kilómetros por hora
cuánto tiempo le llevará al auto a
alcanzar ave y adelantarlo 8 kilómetros
bueno no tenemos los datos nos dicen que
aquí está el auto que tiene una
velocidad de 58 kilómetros por hora más
adelante está el auto ve que viaja a 50
kilómetros por hora y de aquí a acá hay
una distancia de 20 kilómetros el auto a
está atrás del auto ve por 20 kilómetros
y lo que nos están preguntando es cuánto
tiempo le llevará al auto a no solo a
alcanzar al auto vecino rebasarlo y
adelantarse a él ocho kilómetros
bueno otra forma de ver lo que nos piden
es determinar cuánto tiempo le lleva el
auto a recorrer 28 kilómetros que sería
toda esta distancia completa para
sobrepasar al auto ve para eso
necesitamos ver cuál es la diferencia de
velocidad entre los autos a ive quedamos
que el auto ve baja 50 y a 58 la
diferencia es de 8 kilómetros el auto a
viaja a 8 kilómetros por hora más rápido
que el auto ve la velocidad relativa de
a con respecto a bs 8 kilómetros que no
se nota bien la casa 8 kilómetros a qué
se refiere esto de velocidad relativa
quiere decir que si yo estuviera a bordo
del autobús y estuviera mirando hacia el
auto yo percibiría que este auto a se
está acercando o se está moviendo con
relación a donde yo estoy que para mí yo
estoy quieta en este auto ve a 8
kilómetros por hora entonces cuánto
tiempo le llevará al auto
recorrer 28 km bueno es 28 km lo que me
interesa recorrer y la velocidad
relativa es de 8 kilómetros por hora
esto es igual a 28 entre 83 y media
horas que es la opción el siguiente
problema problema número 224 durante los
últimos n días la producción promedio de
cierta fábrica fue de 50 unidades por
día si la producción del día de hoy es
de 90 unidades lo que eleva el promedio
a 55
cuál es el valor de n
nos dicen que n es es el número de días
en el que en promedio se fabricaron 50
unidades por día
en promedio
y nos dicen que hoy se produjeron 90
unidades lo que cambió el promedio a 55
unidades por día bueno entonces el viejo
promedio era en el número de días por
las 50 unidades promedio entre n
qué es algo obvio en el tren es igual a
1 y queda 50 esto es igual a 50 si ahora
le agrego lo del día de hoy esto me va a
quedar como n por 50 más 90 entre n más
1 y esto va a ser igual ahora a 55 bueno
vamos a despejar n de aquí voy a
multiplicar todo por n 1 me va a quedar
n por 50 que es igual a 50 n más 90
igual a 55 por n 55 n más 55 por 155
préstamos 50 n de ambos lados nos va a
quedar 90 igual a 55 m 50 n 5 n más 55 y
restamos 55 en ambos lados 90 - 55 me va
a quedar 35 igual a 5 y ahora dividido
todo en 31 ene es igual a 30 y 55 que es
igual a 7 el número de días 7 y este es
mi opciones veamos el siguiente problema
problema número 225 x + 1 / x menos 1 al
cuadrado cuando x es diferente de 0 y x
es diferente de uno si x se reemplaza
por uno entre x en esta expresión a que
ese día equivalente bueno pues vamos a
reemplazar a ver qué sucede tengo x que
la reemplazó por 1 / x 1 / x + 1 / 1 / x
menos 1 todo esto al cuadrado bueno esto
es igual un entero puedo decir que es
igual a x entre x y hago la zona de
manera que es 1 / x + x entre x es igual
a 1 + x entre x y lo mismo hago aquí
abajo 1 entre x menos x entre x me va a
quedar x y aquí 1 - x todo esto al
cuadrado bueno eso también lo puedo
poner como es el numerador multiplicado
por el recíproco del denominador me
queda que esto es igual a 1 + x entre x
por el recíproco de uno menos x entre x
x entre 1 - x todo esto al cuadrado que
no se nos olvide que está elevado al
cuadrado ok aquí estas x se van y esto
me va a quedar igual a b y lo puedo
cambiar de orden x más uno entre x menos
1 x menos 1 esto es lo mismo si yo
multiplico menos 1 por esto me va a
quedar uno menos x a pero porque hago
esto así no olvidemos que está elevado
al cuadrado esto no puedo expresar como
x + 1 / x menos 1 al cuadrado por 1
entre menos 1 al cuadrado saco esta
parte que está multiplicando todo esto
esto lo pueden ver como uno entre menos
uno que está multiplicando a todo esto
pero este número al cuadrado este menos
1 al cuadrado va a ser igual a 1 así que
creen me queda exactamente la misma
expresión que al principio x + 1 / x
menos 1 al cuadrado que es mi opción y
el chiste era darse cuenta de que
teníamos algo al cuadrado y que esto de
aquí abajo lo podíamos factorizar con
menos 1 y luego elevarlo al cuadrado de
manera que nos quedaba nada más un 1 y
el mismo resultado que la expresión
inicial con eso terminamos este vídeo y
nos vemos en el siguiente